thank you
[Music]
and everybody welcome back to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today is all about cans yeah I hate you
can I love you love you too dude can't
this part where you riff all right so uh
the other day I was um at my office and
I was typing up some stuff and then I
was like dear Nick I really love the way
that you roast me on JK and I really
think it comes from a genuine place
because I think you actually hate me and
I just want to say that
I'm gonna uh hate you back every day all
the time you type like that love can and
I sent you an email you sent me an email
yeah you check check your phone I'm just
kidding I didn't send it I got him oh I
reached my phone that was me riffing bro
can't tell us and and the family of
friends and fans out there fans the fans
fans tell us something that you've never
told anybody
oh man that's a tough one huh yep I
don't know what what have I never told
anybody
uh uh dude I can't think of it I have no
how long have you been at JK how long
I think since I lived with you
so what year was it however long that
when was that 2000 2013.
2014 probably
14. a lot of something that Joe's done
that like pissed you off the most
oh dude actually you know what's funny
you never actually pissed me off to the
point where I was like oh God damn it
Joe like but there were like sometimes I
was just like dude this is what it's
like living with Joe living with him
yeah yeah please please elaborate we
lived no we lived no it's got to be
longer than 2013. no it was only like
2009 and [__] no no not that long I was
still I barely got out of high school
then okay okay yeah but I knew you back
then though
that would have been weird if I lived
with you that's the things that Joe did
that pissed you off ah dude he's never
done anything that pissed me off really
what was like living all those years he
never deleted your footage I mean the
only thing the only thing maybe like
this is like more my fault was like
telling me to wash the dishes and I was
like oh man I always wash my dishes but
I guess I didn't today and then he
yelled at me
that was it it wasn't that bad so
but he was like it was like living with
like an older brother kind of so it's
that Dynamic ish but but also here he's
like your boss so it's kind of like that
dynamic-ish right yeah but I saw I can't
really say anything because he's he's my
boss no dude
it's the attitude let me take some notes
to make sure for the review I'm gonna
get fired oh oh why I left JK
if you could change anything about JK
what would be
um the whole set really no I win well
because like the paint and stuff I would
definitely change the paint dude it's
just mad old yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
redecorate it for sure if we decorate it
too yeah I don't know anything but like
anything but yeah I know but it's a good
song I would put artwork I would put uh
I would get rid of the couches I would
oh those are not good those are good
couches man no they're not to lay on you
not to sit to Leon not to look at you've
laid down on those yeah dude no I think
we got them for like 200 bucks each
the way it is too but it would be cool
to see it like just different run no we
need it we need to change it who would
you bring back that's not currently on
JK that's a good question oh
bichoy I love beach oh yeah yeah I would
bring him back because he's I lived with
him too so after I live with Joe I live
with Detroit and then me and him were
like we pretty much like play games all
the time smoke weed whatever we hung out
a lot whoa huh what was uh living with B
Troy like it was chill like low stress
like there's barely any like does he
ever ask about me
I don't think he even knew you yet no
I'm talking about now dude now does he
ever ask about me like what's that Nick
guy doing
is that what he sounds like wait do you
do you talk to him now no but every time
I hung out with beach I was like this
dude's cool as hell I really like that
no he's dude he's super cool but uh he's
too bad he's gone now he's like what
number what happened to him get him back
I don't know I think he just left right
I no he's he's no it was like he was
going up there to take care of family
and stuff and he decided to stay and
he's uh he's working in film and stuff
but he's working up there yeah yeah yeah
but a lot of fans say that this is like
the
sickest era of JK do you agree with him
yes I do agree you've been around for
over 10 years now
and you haven't had a raise since how do
you feel about that
um it's not about the money man I don't
care about it
I'm not here to get dude I make the
least amount of money here than anywhere
else you don't have to save it
I'm clearly just here for you didn't
explain why though okay because you have
a whole company now
because what people don't know behind
the scenes is a lot of the people who've
edited for us can't took all their jobs
because he has an editing company now I
didn't take their jobs but yeah um I
pretty much took their jobs but I think
it's because
like what I see in JK is like what I've
always seen in the past where it's like
I used to look up to you guys I still
kind of do as like Bigger Brothers and I
feel like even though you don't think so
I think you guys are good Role Models
like for me personally and so that's why
I look further up right yeah and you
always say that too which I like that's
such a beautiful mind thing to say
because you're not making yourself like
oh I'm the [__] listen to me blah blah
you're like whatever you know no I am
two people below me you have more
potential
really that's a great compliment from
Joe dude
it's really chill and you know it's
never really been about the money it's
just more so like how can we co-exist in
this ecosystem and like Thrive together
that's that's what I really like how
often do you think about me throughout
the day at least once a day really yeah
I go I wonder what Nick's eating today
because he he would be telling me what
to eat what kind of role model is Nick
to you huh what kind of role model is
Nick to you uh I think Nick yeah I hate
I don't know I don't really hate this
[__] [__] I [__] hate you what
was your first impression in this Nick
I was like who's this guy that's the
right answer that's a really good first
impression it's like yo where do you
where did you come from yeah why you
look so weird yeah what what's up with
his ears you know all right dude that's
enough
all right that's too far okay in your
opinion when you say that you do believe
that this era of JK is like amongst your
favorite along with the fans why do you
think that is why I think because you
guys just don't give a [__] anymore like
about what you do but you don't sounds
like an insult more than a compliment
you don't care about your company you
don't care about your voice
and it makes it good because when you
try when you're like a tryhard I don't
really like tryhards who would you who
would you say is a tryhard this guy
yeah
man you fighting you look too hard with
those ears that's not funny you guys we
need to cut this yeah Ken you need to
edit this out no but I don't think this
is like I'm gonna I'm gonna my ears are
tearing up a little my ears are ringing
they're swelling up
they're getting bigger and bigger it's
just like kind of hard no I I really do
think the attitude matters it's not like
you don't care about the work itself
it's more so like how you're carrying
yourself while you're doing the work
yeah you know that's a good call so I I
can see that and I see that you guys are
more happy you know because I like to
see my friends happy and I used to see
you guys when you weren't happy when was
that when was the least happy time
probably like three years ago really
maybe four I don't know what was the
tone from your point of view it was more
careful it was actually careful oh it
really was literally it's like oh no it
fell hell back you're right not do this
and do that because of what people think
you gotta edit so what kind of things
did you what kind of things did you hear
and see
after the cameras would cut back then
uh not it was it didn't feel like
natural so so you know how when we cut
it's still the conversation still keeps
going it's still fun and whatever
whatever no don't give them our secrets
they've already seen it supposed to be
completely different but like before it
was like cut and then the faces turn off
and it'd be like that yeah because
because as an editor as an editor I
wasn't here yet like I used to not be in
the back room but even when I'm editing
it you can see it when you cut but then
the footage keeps going like you could
see it damn yeah yeah but it wasn't like
like obvious it was more subtle you know
what I mean but you could tell
so what do you want to say to the fans
that uh actually believe that you live
in this room
um give him a message dang uh thank you
guys for watching because without you
guys I wouldn't be you know I would be
homeless right now yeah
it's on you know the only reason why I'm
here is because of you guys he can't
even use the AC when we're not filming
yeah keep it off I get sweaty yeah
there's no windows so that's that's why
I'm skinny I don't get sunned is that
why people yeah my bones are brutal
if you had to look Joe in the face and
in the eyes right now and ask for a
raise how much would you ask how much
does that for a percentage-wise where
would you be comfortable how would you
back up that request
um Joe's going bar right now we get
about let me think let me do this don't
get real numbers
percentages like you or be like cut it
out anyways double I would ask for
because you took 40 off of before I
would add
I would say like 20 back on damn that's
hella nice you didn't get reduced though
oh I did it I thought I did debate back
I think it felt like it nah
okay we're not even here we're not even
here so you say you didn't ask for a
raise in 10 plus years oh that's true I
mean
I think if you want to give me a raise I
think it should be like
as much as Nick's getting at least I
have to actually know a little more than
anything like Nixon least paid one here
dude you gotta ask someone else yeah
dude I don't get paid much dollars an
hour make mine 10.50 no it's just not
[__] say that he gets 100 and I want
to base it off him you're a little do
that [__] bro
huh he gets 100 an hour oh do what a
hundred uh give me like a hundred and
five dollars
that would be the same ratio as 10 and
10.50 that's good math is it
maybe yeah I can't do math right now but
I would whatever he's getting give me
like why'd you pick me because I hate
you bro
I like the adding up bro um out of all
the videos you deleted which one do you
regret the most ah none of them it was
all trash no regrets no regrets no I I
feel like
that that was a pretty big oofy doofy
I feel like I made it and not by
re-editing I try to use editing skills
yeah but yeah and then it happened again
but this is fault it was
no so it happens but it's okay like with
the power of editing you know we can
save things you can't save it if you
never recorded exactly
with the power of anything oh you can I
I saved it I saved it with screenshots
of other videos oh that's great and then
we I could do ADR or something dude yeah
let's do voiceover yeah save it you
could save the footage that was never
recorded buy a bunch of stock footage
edit that has nothing to do with Jake
there's a lot of stock footage of Nick
yeah and just Nick narrating over stock
footage yeah perfect who's been your
favorite and least favorite guest to
come on the show that's a good question
oh I don't know
like me watching or me just just in
general just watching and editing
whatever we're both being Vibes I think
favorite guests this year
well does it count if they're like
currently like like recurring because I
like I like to lean on here
you don't have to say that you're not a
guest anymore you know what do you like
about it like you're like what do you
not like about it yeah what do you not
like about me clean yeah what why is she
the best and worst yeah why am I the
best it's hard to say it's hard to say
and worse why is the hardest why am I
the best at being in the world a lot
there's not a lot dude not like you wait
is that does that make sense that's a
good answer wow
I came in during a time that is very
natural
male yeah I mean Fair the future's male
dude
that's all right
okay so non-recurring non-recurring yes
what up what up
the pictures male
maybe dude it's gotta be that guy that
real estate
do you know what I'm talking about
that's [__] up I wasn't here that day
he's the best you know what I'm talking
about it's not his fault it's not his
fault I'm just gonna say real estate
it was a weird [__] day bro it was a
weird weekend he had no like prior
explanation he didn't know why he was
here and the whole time he didn't know
what was going on and he didn't know any
of us it's like I don't like him as a
guest on the show but as a person he's
really cool oh so what I mean so that's
not fair to him because
other than that all of our guests are
actually really great like everybody has
something to contribute to the room so
Bart brought a guest on and didn't even
really explain [__] and he didn't show
up that day yeah oh wow I think what
happened too was the first time he was
here it was during the pandemic and you
guys were talking purely about real
estate so I think when he came on he was
expecting to purely talk about real
estate and then we're like Kevin what do
you think about three kids dying in
Florida
it's bad I guess and we're like let's
make jokes about that so poor [__]
guy has to sit here and just look at
like what the [__]
[__] what do you think about that
you ever sell any joke houses
we just did like because he was here for
regular articles plus otrs and we did a
bunch of like regular stuff it's like he
didn't know where the pocket was to talk
he would have like a whole 10 minute no
word type deal oh I would say that's
hard to do just naturally exactly yeah
plus we all thought we were being
pranked so we kind of took it half
serious yeah oh Honestly though my
favorite configuration of like the
people sitting here it's always just the
OG cast like careful boys like because
some of those videos like I laughed the
hardest yeah yeah you actually like
audibly laugh out loud yeah because I
have to I'm like watching it and then
like Steve or someone is just saying
something so dumb and I can't like not
laugh these are dumb things all the time
he's the dumbest Sayer
dude the fat con one was [__] funny
oh dude fat con was rough oh yeah
and this guy's just like trying not to
crack up as hard
that made it so much funnier
funnier
people people started to comment being
like yo they changed the thumbnail so I
changed it yeah we changed it yeah we're
trying to increase
of our thumbnails you know I look like I
was [__] getting the cramp from
laughing that's why it was so funny dude
it was great and then you use the actual
photo of like the fat con speakers that
made it so bad without contact I didn't
even know who that was that was the
keynote speaker wasn't that your article
Anthony what are you talking no it is
almost getting [__] thrown on the bus
for other people's [__] he's the one who
presented the article I didn't get any
damage but it's like stuff like that
where it's like you don't expect it to
be funny because it's like oh just
another regular cast video but then
something like there's always gold
nuggets in those videos yeah there were
chocolate do you ever watch or edit the
videos that you're in and laugh at
something you said uh no not really I
just watched it and I'm like turn my
brain off and I just go through it I'm
not like watching myself and go oh you
know that was it yeah that's so weird
he's like that's a good taste what a
favorite guest oh favorite guess did I
not say it yet no we heard your least
favorite that's for sure yeah you said
Colleen it clean's your least favorite
yeah she's recurring wait I'm the best
of the worst she's the best recurring
best recurring or non-recurring
they're probably Jesus man oh wow
because he's good vibes because he talks
continue well you you said Jesus and
then Jesus popped up what it says Jesus
first century Jewish preacher and
religious leader central figure how did
I not listen to anything else until you
said Jesus
it's the magic word dude yeah he's
really funny because like even off
camera like he's just cool with
everybody we're talking like yeah it's
like being at a show when he's talking
yeah yeah no he's good he brings the
energy up for sure yeah I like I like
Jesus I like Jesus who's your least
favorite uh regular cast least favorite
regular cast damn dude I can't answer
that dude that's like like an
unanswerable question for me no you
totally can no way dude all right just
keep saying who your favorite one is and
then the next one
no you can say it dude I can't say it
it's It's gotta be Nick all right what's
the beef dude dude because you're the
new guy
you're the new guy and it's my duty to
give you [__] that's oh you're oh he's
pulling this in you're already thinking
oh booty your new booty I'm gonna handle
this booty boy let me tell you that
you're fresh fish yeah dude yeah all
right I took that yeah all right it's
out of respect though hey [__] you can
imma give you a 40 race oh [__] shut up
50 reduction
plus 10 percent
plus ten percent so it's back to zero
nine
hey dude I appreciate it you're welcome
it's a really Dynamic work environment
this guy's good at math what I mean man
boss of the year right here a question
numbers baby
so I did bring it up and bring it down I
don't know who's the better well I I
talked to Joe more so I feel like Joe's
so Bart's just like he's just not around
he's just like no because he takes care
of other things not attentive yeah he's
Debbie dad I go to bar for scheduling I
go to Joe for like
create the creative stuff inside the
internal creatives does your favorite
host favorite house oh say it just say
it yeah I won't be offended if you say
Ryan but you say Steve I'm sure
gonna say I was gonna say Steve because
you two are here
turn the camera